okay so we've been talking about with
the virus should we be voting by mail in
November and Donald Trump has insisted
that vote by mail leads to voter fraud
despite the fact that he votes by mail
we've talked about really it's the swing
states the battlegrounds that are most
important to ensure we can vote by mail
so that we don't hold down Democratic
turnout in a vote by mail or not
California's going to Joe Biden vote by
mail or not Massachusetts is going to
Joe Biden but it's those key swing
states and even some battleground or
purplish red states where it's really
important that voting by mail be done we
know that higher turnout is bad for
Republicans and we have really really
good news Texas federal judge has ruled
yesterday that anyone who doesn't want
to go out and vote in person in Texas
because they are afraid of catching
coronavirus is entitled to get an
absentee ballot now this is not as good
as vote by mail by default and I'll
explain to you why the best scenario
would be the state says every registered
voter is going to get an absentee ballot
in the mail whether they request one or
not this is not that you do have to
request an absentee ballot but in normal
circumstances in Texas you have to
justify why are you asking for an
absentee ballot you have to meet certain
criteria and it would be a fight over
does fear of catching the virus
qualified qualify you for an absentee
ballot we've now heard from District
Judge Fred berry and judge Fred berry
says the disability provision applies to
any voter who does not have immunity to
coronavirus and fears they would catch
it at a polling place this is a very
technical ruling Texas has this Election
Code which defines a disability as a
sickness or physical condition that
prevents the voter from appearing at the
polling place on Election Day without a
likelihood of needing personal
assistance or of injuring the voters
health the court said fear and anxiety
is inextricably intertwined with voters
physical health and if you are
apprehensive about going to the vote to
going to the in-person ballot box and
catching coronavirus that is a limb
on your ability to cast the ballots so
the court decided lack of immunity to
the karate to the coronavirus counts as
a physical condition you would be
entitled to request an absentee ballot
under that pretence now there's a few
caveats here um you will be able to do
this request an absentee ballot merely
for fear of catching coronavirus until
this decision goes to trial or the
pandemic goes away so I don't know how
you define the pandemic has gone away in
November if there are fewer cases if
there are fewer deaths would that
potentially be seen as there is no more
pandemic and voters will not be allowed
to vote for president by mail right now
this will apply to the July elections in
Texas for example July 14th there's a
primary runoff in Texas anybody who is
afraid of catching coronavirus will be
able to request an absentee ballot
November is still more of a question
mark and of course Republicans don't
like it they're going to fight to have
this cancelled by the time of the
presidential election you've got the
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton who
says that this could be something that
opens the door to fraud and this is the
talking point that the right is choosing
to die on essentially it's the hill
they're choosing to die on voting by
mail should be available to anybody who
wants it period the entire state of
Oregon has had vote-by-mail for twenty
years more than twenty years they've put
it in place in 1998 they had a ballot
initiative it passed about 70 to 30 and
it's funny how you look at the arguments
in 1998 against about 97 98 against
vote-by-mail in Oregon and it's the
exact same thing that Republicans are
saying right now you go back and look at
the comments in the 90s in Oregon from
people like state Rep Lynn Snodgrass or
anti-tax activist bill Sizemore in the
90s they were saying we can't have vote
by mail in Oregon it'll invite election
fraud it'll allow people to pressure
others about how they vote now the truth
is vote by mail is very popular in
Oregon eighty-one percent support in
2003 really hard to get eighty percent
support for anything right now but more
importantly thirty percent of
respondents in Oregon in 2003 said they
vote more often since
by mail wasn't active enacted that is
what Republicans don't want that is what
scares the hell out of Trump about
vote-by-mail for November of 2020
let's put vote-by-mail in place in more
places and let's also understand that we
should really focus in on the swing
states now on the fraud question
vote-by-mail does not lead to more fraud
check out the numbers that we have over
the last twenty years two hundred and
fifty million votes have been cast by
mail nationally
twelve hundred cases of voter fraud in
all forms have been identified eleven
hundred resulting in criminal
convictions so what do we know over the
last twenty years we have had almost no
actual voter fraud it almost always
eleven hundred out of twelve hundred
times it led to a criminal conviction
meaning you are very likely to get
punished and be found guilty if you
participate in voter fraud and when you
look at how many of those were with
absentee ballots it's only two hundred
of the twelve hundred okay
so of the almost non-existent voter
fraud 1,200 cases one-sixth were with
absentee ballots that means seven or
eight cases per year nationally okay
seven or eight not seven or eight
percent not 0.7 or 0.8%
seven or eight cases nationally per year
of absentee ballot related voter fraud
which is only one sixth of the total
most of them are in person no
methodology is perfect fraud is not an
issue with vote-by-mail do not let them
trick you make them provide the evidence
of it because there is no evidence the
numbers are overwhelming